estamos en una población conocida como
humana en el centro del país y hasta
ahora suenan las alarmas lo que indica
que la población tiene que buscar
refugio tener cuidado para un bombardeo
los hoteles de esta población están
llenas de personas que buscan refugio ya
sea de la capital que está asediada o ni
bloqueos fue bombardeada también por las
fuerzas rusas tras lo que vimos esta
mañana provenientes desde el este en una
línea recta hacia el centro fue miles y
miles y miles de carros que van buscando
refugio ya sea en esta ciudad desde esta
parte del país o para llevar a sus
familias para cruzar la frontera según
las naciones unidas 2.5 millones de
ucranianos han abandonado al país hasta
el momento pero también dos millones de
personas han buscado refugio en otras
ciudades del país aunque esta cifra es
bastante difícil de calcular pues
muchísimas personas se quedan
simplemente con familiares lo que sí es
cierto y por lo que vimos hoy es que
habrá muchísimo más personas abandonando
el país o buscando refugio en otras
ciudades porque los bombardeos continúan